it's actually pretty crazy to think
dominic cruz versus pedro munoz who are
two top 10 bantamweights dominick cruz
was arguably one of the best
bantamweights of all time
are on my prelims now at this point i
called out dominick cruz dominic cruz
could have said yes to fighting me and
been on the main event our main card
which doesn't really [ __ ] matter i'm
not getting paid any more money to be on
the main card than if i was the first
fight of the night like it's not my job
to go out there and sell this fight it's
charles oliveira and dustin poyer
they're getting pay-per-view points i
don't know if both of them are or just
charles because he's the champ right i
think it's just the champion like
they're getting he has to sell a fight i
don't have to sell a fight at in this
position so being on the main card and
being on the prelims i don't really know
it like it's similar to the rankings
like it doesn't really matter
but it kind of does
it it depends what uh how you look at it
but it's just crazy to think those two
bantamweights top 10
fighting for potentially title shots are
on the prelims
and they said no and dominic cruz had
notified me i called i did call both of
them out i called dominic cruz out and
he made it known like he did not he's
not gonna fight me for whatever reason
obviously he's not gonna say i don't
wanna fight him
right like he said it because i'm not
ranked or what like i don't it just does
it makes no sense to me yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so
it's adults only and if you live in any
of these states then you better go to
stevo.com and check out my tour schedule
hurry up and get your tickets too
because it's selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude